foreign
[Music]
over the past two years we've been
working on this workflow that's been
helpful for us in processing large
amounts of data very quickly in order to
create products that help guide the
decision making in the state of where to
allocate resources this workflow
involves three main products Microsoft
Azure devops our studio workbench and
RSU connect if you're at the keynote
this morning you'll realize these some
of these terms are a little outdated
since we're now are you just changing to
pause it
when I first started working at cdph it
was December 2020. I was living in
Washington DC in Foggy Bottom so not too
far from here and if you remember in our
personal lives it was quite stressful so
going outside was kind of like rolling
the dice or whether you might get sick
or get others sick
and you can imagine working in public
health is also quite stressful our
infrastructure wasn't prepared for the
amount of data that Kobe was going to
provide and we're often trying to catch
up and get ahead
I happen to be working on a report at
that time that got sent out at the end
of the day of the day and I would get
this beautiful data set that was
processed by my many colleagues from the
local health jurisdictions and at the
state level and sometimes there would be
delays to no fault that anyone the
situation was very complicated data was
always changing so this often meant 9 pm
10 pm 11 pm California time midnight 1am
2 A.M and DC so I have to look like this
I was very tired and my cat was
wondering why I'm still awake
as a team we knew this wasn't feasible
and we needed to do something to change
this not only to meet the needs of the
state but also to improve our work-like
balance So eventually this workflow came
about allowing us to do our work more
efficiently and I got into bed at a more
reasonable time
so reducing our stress required four
main things the first one is how we
prioritize our task
how do we improve our ability to
collaborate with each other
how do we decrease our turnaround time
and then lastly how do we scale our work
so I'm going to start with or how do we
improve our prioritization so during
this time there are many requests always
coming in and there's often underturned
up I needed this yesterday and that's
very true because this the questions and
issues that we're having impacted the
health of millions of people
and the issue however is that as a team
we're quite limited there's only so many
of us our skills vary and we want to be
able to solve these issues but we only
have so much time as well so we needed
to wait to prioritize how we move
forward in our work
so that's where first product comes in
Microsoft Azure devops and we use
microsoftware develops at cdph because
we're a Microsoft Shop but you could use
other devop platforms as well in place
of this
so we started using Azure devops for
project management in particular a
Sprint board and a Sprint is a defined
period of time that you set to complete
a number of tasks and what's really
great about a Sprint is that at the very
beginning of the Sprint it forces you to
sit down and decide what what needs to
be done
what can realistically be done in this
time period and who's going to do it
and for us we happen to use a two week
Sprint time but you could use a
different amount of time as well
so what I'm going to do next is show you
what I spent our Sprint boat looks like
to give you a sense of that
so we have five columns features not
started the client in progress and done
in the feature column you're going to
have a overarching project so for
example preparing for this R Studio
conference talk
and within that you're going to have a
number of tasks to complete within your
Sprint
so in the not started I might have tasks
about drafting slides or practicing this
presentation and you can view the judge
of whether I successfully did these or
not
I may have decline columns such as
adding cat gifts and at some point
realized or decided this wasn't a
professional enough thing to add so I'm
not going to do that
I'll have it in progress column such as
drafting outline which I need to do
prior to doing the slides or practicing
my presentation
and then lastly I'll finish a couple of
tasks too so such as making this Sprint
board example which again you can judge
whether I successfully did that or not
and then we'll have other rows with
other features for separate tasks and
these this creates a really great
visualization for a team of how we're
doing in the Sprint
and what's really powerful is that as
Sprints continue to occur we can look
back in time and see how successful
we're at completing our task and modify
how we were going to move forward in the
next Sprint
and if you're disappointed that I didn't
add any cat gives I added some last
minute for you
so next how did we improve our
collaboration so when I first started we
were using git and devops principles in
some places but it wasn't a main part of
our workflow so a lot of our work was
shared across a shared drive or folder
in at work and that often meant copying
your our script for example and then
making edits and later putting it back
together which over time we're starting
to make a lot of problems especially
when it came down to production or it
was late at night at midnight and edits
are just very frustrating and tiring to
do
um so we started to use get principle
get or get workflow more effectively and
made it a main part of our workflow
so if you think about our work in our
studio workbench it's kind of like we're
in a silo it's really hard to share this
work with others or the colleagues and
we want to be able to do that
so that's where we started using
repositories via zero devops and a
repository is a slice a place where you
can store your code safely have Version
Control and it's the central place that
all of your your work can live
and what's great about this is that via
our studio and get we can move our work
outside of our work outside of our Silo
into this repository and that same vein
I can move other people's work from the
repositories into my workbench and work
on it there
now you can have an entire Workshop
about git and still may not understand
it it's very confusing but it's a really
great resource by Jenny Bryan called
happygit that's related to using git and
R that I highly encourage you to check
out if you want to get started with
getting r
so you can think of repositories as if
you're storing your code safely so in
these photos by Edward Newbridge we're
seeing this the spirit in flight and
we're getting snapshots snapshots of it
over time and you can think of our code
every time we make a commit or a save
we're saving a version of it in memory
in a repository
so maybe you want to put this last
snapshot into production but something
goes wrong
what's great about repository is that we
can roll back the clock and use this
previous version to go into production
and in the meantime fix our errors that
occurred later on
another another really great feature is
that you can make what's called a fork
or a branch repository and that's like
making a copy of it and you can kind of
think of it as if you're working in your
own lane in that sense we're all running
in the Sprint and I have my own fork or
branch and I'm working it making edits
and if I happen to make a mistake it's
not going to affect others in their Lane
so it gives us a really great
opportunity to try new things out fall
over break the app all those things that
we don't want to happen during
production
and lastly how did we improve our
turnaround time and scalability so we're
always getting requests and lots of data
that we're taking ownership of and these
data processing can take hours
and at the same time we also want to be
able to scale our work and share it with
others
so that's where our final product comes
in our studio connect and this is a
server that allows you to automate your
processes and what's really cool is that
from a repositories and Azure devops we
can deploy our work into our studio
connect
and from connect we can automate data
processing we can schedule reports
and we can post shiny apps
so RCA connect provided us more
processing power which allowed us to do
analyzes more quickly so just as an
example this is one of our servers we
have about 251 gigabytes of RAM which is
a lot or another example the amount of
CPU queries available and we have a
number of these servers available to us
to do different types of data processing
or host apps and I can can't explain the
giddiness I felt the first time I ran a
script on connect that took 10 minutes
when it used to take over an hour to run
if it didn't crash so connect was a
really great life saver in terms of
finishing or data processing in more
quickly quick manner allowing me to go
to sleep earlier
so it's not only quicker but it also
feed up our hands at least in our
environment we're limited to two
workbenches so it's kind of like having
two our consoles or two tabs and if I
have many types of data that I need to
process throughout the week it's as if
my hands are tied so by being able to
offset it off to a server I can free up
my hands to do other type of work
and we can schedule jobs on the server
I'm using for example the officer or
open xlsx package to make PowerPoints
Excel sheets or Word Documents
um in that same theater processing we
can also be doing the data the large
amount of data processing and then
creating reports that are outputted at a
scheduled time
and we can schedule emails with the
Blaster package and a couple emails here
and there is not too bad but when we
start to you need to share your emails
and data with a lot of different
partners this becomes a really great
tool to use
and here's one example of data that we
put on the website weekly for post
vaccination infection data if you want
to check it out and all of this data is
processed via connect and then shared
with our partners at cdpage to later
publish on the website
so we can kind of think of connect as if
they're replacing this they're robots
they're running in their own lane and
they're running their own processes
and it's at this point I might want to
sit back and look at my cat and listen
to her and stop looking at this monitor
but in reality automation isn't perfect
and it often actually fails and can be
quite challenging to debug I'm working
on a server the debugging process is a
lot different the logs are different so
we we tried to so we need to think about
that as well so in reality it's more
like this we're all running in the same
Lane some of the processes are falling
over I'm falling over Etc
and one of the solutions to this is was
to create a data processing monitoring
app so this monitors all of our
processes on connect and it gives us a
really great visualization of what's
occurring and when it might fail
and in addition to that we have an error
logging system where if something breaks
we get an email via blastula telling us
something's broken and where in that
script it broke so I don't have time to
share that with you right now but if
you're interested and there's actually a
talk by my colleagues Colby Parish Andy
fan coming up next that you can check
out to see that specific piece of our
workflow
and then lastly we have many different
chatting apps mostly internal that I
can't share with you but one of those
published to the public by the
California covid-19 modeling team called
Calcutt and this shows you the current
state and predicted feature State using
different models of covid-19 in the
state of California so encourage you to
check this out and see the different
types of data that we're working with
and what's I think really cool is that
you can download the data as well that
we've all been processing and that's
updated regularly
so this gives you a very high level
overview of the different tools that we
use to create this workflow using Azure
devops RSV workbench and our studio
connect allowing us to process data in a
very quick amount of time and freeing up
our hands to make products that help
guide decision making in the state of
where to allocate resources
so thank you all for your time and
special thanks to data processing and
informatics section for all our homework
[Applause]
[Music]